until twenty years ago the prevailing
theory for how the earliest human
settlers arrived in America came down to
one thing being gay it was thought that
humans followed megafauna such as
mammoths and bison across the Bering
Strait and through an ice-free corridor
down into North America around 13,500
years ago these early humans the Clovis
left behind spearpoint telltale grooves
evidence of their big-game hunt but this
theory collapsed when evidence of human
occupation dating to 14,500 years ago
was found at the Monteverdi site in
Chile a thousand years before Clovis
points appear in North America this gave
rise to a new theory the humans may have
traveled by boat
starting in Beringia and sailing down
the coast some 16,000 years ago since
the discovery of Monte Verde researchers
have turned their attention to the
Pacific coast in search of early sites
Cedros island is practically brimming
with archaeological evidence for an
early american culture that had mastered
coastal environments stone tools and
clam shells found at several sites on
the island where radiocarbon dated to
between 11,000 and 13,000 years ago
not quite pre-clovis but getting there
in the hunt for evidence of these early
settlers researchers have been searching
not only on land but also under the sea
as the ice sheets covering North America
began to melt around sixteen thousand
five hundred years ago the sea level
rose 120 meters like lys whomping any
early settlements along the Pacific
coast
uncover these drown settlements
researchers tried to deduce the location
of these settlers most important
resource freshwater they started mapping
the ocean floor of the coasts of Oregon
and California in search of evidence of
ancient riverbanks and estuaries by
taking core samples of the ocean floor
where these river banks lie researchers
hope to understand these lost
environments and perhaps even eventually
find evidence of early human occupation
as the glaciers melted in sea levels
rose parts of the coasts of British
Columbia and southwestern Alaska Rosas
well no longer bearing the weight the
massive sheets of ice the consequences
of this geological quirk can be found on
Calvert island where the sea-level rise
was as little as two meters
leaving easily accessible evidence of
coastal settlements here researchers
found 29 footprints preserved in clay
buried underneath a half a meter of soil
a piece of wood embedded in one of the
footprints allow them to date the
footprints suggest over 13,000 years ago
more evidence has been found on nearby
coastal islands twelve thousand seven
hundred year old spearpoints leftover
from a bear hunt and fourteen thousand
year old stone tools left next to a
heart Clues that the first Americans
made their way down the coast by boat
continued to present themselves but
archaeologists aren't ready to confirm
the theory just yet
a string of well-documented sites along
the coast of southwestern Alaska and
British Columbia dating back to at least
15,000 years ago and extending through
time down the coast will be needed to
truly prove the coastal migration theory
until then archaeologists in both North
and South America will continue the hunt
for signs as the earliest Americans were
indeed seafaring people
[Music]